multiply and simplify five times the
cube root of 2x squared times three
times the cube root of 4x to the fourth
so the two things that pop out in my
brain right here is that we can change
the order a little bit because
multiplication is both commutative well
the commutative property allows us to
switch the order for multiplication and
so we can get the constant term so we
can multiply the 5 times the 3 and then
the other two things that we're
multiplying they're both the cube root
which is the same thing as taking
something to the 1/3 power so the cube
root of x this is exactly the same thing
as raising X to the 1/3 so let's do that
let's switch the order and let's rewrite
these cube roots as raising it to the
1/3 power so I have the 5 and the 3 so
that's going to be 5 times 3 and then we
have the cube root of do that in a new
color
then we have the cube root of 2x squared
so this I can rewrite as 2x squared to
the 1/3 power and then I have the cube
root of 4x to the 4th so that's the same
thing as 4x to the 4th to the 1/3 power
and now we know from our exponent
properties if we have two things that
are both raised to the same power and
then we take the product we could just
take the product first and then raise it
to the power so if I have a a to the X
power times B to the X power this is the
same thing as a times B to the X power
so we can simplify this part of the
expression right over here as 2x squared
2x squared times 4x to the fourth to the
1/3 power and of course 5 times 3 is 15
and if we simplify what's in the
expression right over here we once again
it's commutative so we can swap the
order and and it's associative and so we
can swap the groupings or the grouping
how we group them doesn't matter because
it's all multiplication here this is 2
times 4 which is 6 times x squared times
X to the fourth x squared times X to the
fourth is X to the sixth power and it's
all of that to the 1/3 power and then
that is times that oh sorry not 6 2
times 4 is 8
what am i doing two times four is eight
two times four is eight x squared times
X 2x squared times X to the fourth is X
to the sixth I think my brain was adding
the exponents and wrote the six down of
course two times four is eight not six
but we add the exponents they have the
same base x squared times x squared
times X to the fourth is X to the sixth
and we're going to raise that to the 1/3
power and then all of that is times 15
and then we essentially can use this
property yet actually not that property
we know that this we know if I have
something
well actually exactly this property
again we have something multiplied to a
power this is the exact same thing this
is the exact same thing as 8 to the 1/3
power times X to the sixth to the 1/3
power and then all of that is being
multiplied all of that is being
multiplied by 15 and so 8 to the 1/3
power that's the same thing as the cube
root of 8 you might recognize that 8 is
2 times 2 times 2 so 8 to the 1/3 power
is 2 8 is 2 to the third so 2 to the
third to the 1/3 is 2 to the first 2
times 2 times 2 is 8 and X to the 6 to
the 1/3 we know from our exponent
properties that's the same thing as X to
the 6 times 1/3 power or X to the 6
divided by 3 power or 6 divided by 3 is
2 or x squared so that is just x squared
see a 15 times 2 which gives us 30 so
that's these terms right over here and
then you have this term right over here
I want to do that in a different color
and then you have this term right over
that's not a different color you have
this term right over here is x squared
and you are done it there's a bunch of
ways you could do it you might not
decide to use exponent notation you
could say look if this is cube root this
is a cube root I can then take the cube
root of the product of both of them so
you don't have to write it one third
here you could just write the cube root
of this whole thing over here and then
depending on how you want to group it in
all the rest you could do this in
different orders as long as you get the
right exponent properties you should be
getting
you should get to this same answer